jazz kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der hacker show wenn
ihr diese hier seht bin ich noch in
österreich ich war diese woche von
donnerstag bis sonntag in österreich und
bin wahrscheinlich am heutigen tag auch
mal unterwegs aber die hacker schon habe
ich für euch frau produziert und ich
würde sagen zum ersten mal in der
geschichte dieser sendung dieses format
am anfang nicht endlos viel scheiße
sondern fangen direkt an mit der erste
an diesem hintergrund die heißt hacker
in bakuba quarks und stammt von jad
crafter pvp okay was bei uns alles klar
eine kleine wir sind man die da wieder
wichtig gegen sprint ganz wichtig
natürlich also erst mal leute bevor wir
jetzt darauf eingehen was diese hacker
der macht warum spielleute back wars
back die ihn verfolgt das die zuschauer
auf fische waren zwei gesehen und fische
gruppe 2 kraft der pvp confirm für war
o2 o2 war schon jetzt fällt ist die
optische warengruppen ist für maroh 4
die waren zu blöd die zahl viel zu
schreiben und damit der zahl vier die
zeitreihen geschrieben
ich sage ja ich glaube dass man hier mit
wem wird official erdkrater pvp in faro
vier teams
mit escape mit um gespielt wo damit
konkret beim favoriten in die kommentare
jetzt dieses thema bestes video er
versucht wegzurennen petersen spielt er
herunter used sogar noch die endtabelle
kommt nicht weg damit alles klar
ich verstehe diesen modus sich was
machen die leute die bauen sich ihre wie
hoch und brauchen sich hoch und tricks
sorry leute spazieren da draußen falls
du da draußen backhaus spiels
dieser name allein ich weiß nicht ich
weiß ja nicht leute platz vier als
hacker auf wenig punkte und stammt von
traffics und bevor wir loslegen mit dem
video möchte ich mal eine sache sagen
also die das ganze geschehen das ist
kommt er spielt sich in der lobby ab
also in dem bereich in dem man sich
aufhält bevor das eigentliche spiel
startet eine sache möchte ich klar
machen es macht so wenig sinn in der
gottverdammten lobby zu hacken
dasselbe niveau von dummheit wie in den
screenshot boxen aufkomme zu hacken
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
bisschen omen ist beide die leute sagen
warum menschheit warum gibt es so was an
dieses kind auch noch so jetzt sehen wir
immer in der runde alles da ich glaube
es ist aber nicht nur spyder hat auch
eine ganz komische klar ob die ganze in
die luft und bis beide mal wieder wissen
die anton romako es kommt einer von
kommen gegner als einer von den letzten
drei spielen jetzt hier und da sehen wir
mal kurz easy wir sind ungefähr drei
sekunden in der einsendung drin und wir
haben schon genug gründe und einen
kopfschuss geben und dann wird man es
ist wirklich traurig dass es so einen
typ benutzt auf wenigsurfer spider rag
um in der lobby umzug achseln der traum
wenn 2016
cam
b
platz 34 hacker gigi und stammt von
super green die hd und wie immer kurve
direkt ein
diese interessante echt noch ein
bisschen länger laufen können
ja da haben auf jeden fall schon ein
hacker in welchem modus wird wird
einfach steht und alle weg durch die
blöcke dich auch super ja natürlich
natürlich 1 ob er jetzt alleine ein
ganzes team zu heckt von 4
das ist eigentlich vier ok auf jeden
fall dass der ersten drei roma oder so
hat er andere auch hexe die frage sieht
so weit rechts aus
hier starten momentan schneller gerade
eben auf der brücke drauf und hat einen
hit bekommen bester vor hier gerade wäre
auf ist alles klar
wenn leute einfach ihre sexuellen
vorlieben ihren minecraft namen
schreiben weiß man auch dass die welt
wieder mal einen schritt zu weit
gegangen ist
nein macht es nicht macht es nicht leute
macht das lieber nicht wir jetzt vier
hacker in einem platz als 3 enthält vier
hektar alles klar
und jetzt der nächste
platz 2 stammt von doppelrollen keks
juri und ich würde sagen ich lese man
nicht die titel des videos vor mich zu
spoilern das geschulte auge erkennen du
ja mal wieder ein typ dabei ist der wen
wundert's nicht gespielt was wir machen
können was wir machen können um uns
gegen diesen hacker oberen zu werden wir
ziehen die patentierte kampferprobte
julio press debatten bewährte hacker
einflüsse abwehrende so nutzen wenn man
schreibtisch sehen wollt alles alles
möglich hier einfach an ran an die
brille ist auf der base das kann ihnen
verraten was war das für ein ekliger
sound alter
okay wir rumfliegen aber wird von der
stever getroffen und jetzt packt hin und
her hat glaube ich jemand seine hexen im
griff aber es ist der wird vom schnee
mal getroffen und er backt hin und her
passt nicht gut für ihn aus muss ich
sagen es sieht gar nicht gut aus da und
er wagt noch weiter weg als der andere
immer weiter weg gehen
die in theorie die leute aber das spiel
verlassen diesem moment wenn er seine
hacks nicht mehr funktionieren weil du
von fucking schneeball getroffen wurde
wie dreifach die auslagen ausgeguckten
seine augen leute die ihr stich sie die
traurigkeit und ratlosigkeit drin
er weiß aber nicht besser machen soll
mit seinem leben ok kommen wir zu platz
eins und viel platz ein ziemlich kurz
mal die brille wieder ab wo es hell
alter platz eins ist keine gewöhnliche
einsendung enthält zwar glaube ich schon
hacker aber es ist ein versuch witzigen
momenten sind nicht wirklich als ich mir
die einst ehernen durchgeschaut habt
sagt wo es jetzt nicht den namen von den
teams eingeschickt hat bei der inhalt
eventuell bisschen peinlich sein könnte
ich will nicht dass ich das falsch
verstehen ich mache mich nicht lust über
irgendjemanden oder sonst einfach witzig
ist darüber als abwechslung ganz leis
mal einen etwas ungewöhnlicheren ersten
platz in der show the sun
das ist glaube ich die allererste die
allererste 19 uhr in der hacker schau in
der einfachen vorgang der aufnahme ist
wann nimmt so der hacker show europe und
die mutter im hintergrund so ich glaube
hier nur kurz
ich sage nur kurz bis mittag essen haben
alles klar
vielleicht auch noch was das finde ich
einfach nur geil ich dachte mir so sage
ich habe mir diese 1 sendung angeschaut
oder witzig saß da und dachte mir so
also zuerst fand ich lustig und dann
fall nicht einfach nur krüger die nice
ist einfach wenn deine eigene mutter in
deiner hacker show also überhaupt und
wer folgt auf das will doch keine
sekunde über hacker nachgedacht was
angeschaut haben deswegen schauen wir
erstmal wieder zu ende und geräusche
damit möglich einfach gerade gesagt ja
enjoy enjoy staubsauger alte haye sie
behaupten hacker drin
ja okay doch bei dice neckar ist ja was
willst du was die hacker show ist
familienfreundlich wir nehmen auch
familien mit rein
ferner ist das war es so weit von dieser
erfolge bisschen anders geraten als die
letzten folgen weil ich ein bisschen
zeitdruck habe wegen des produzierens
für österreich denke und hoffe es hat
euch trotzdem gefallen so was ich jetzt
einfach
das hat jetzt schon im video versteht
ihr hat hahaha